the countdown is almost over after years
of planning the stage is set for the
commonwealth games in birmingham
world-class facilities already
benefiting the city's young talented
athletes
it means everything to have the games
right on my doorstep see all the
athletes from all around the world
coming just to where me and going to
compete
organizers want these games to bring
communities together
recently retired champion triple jumper
nathan douglas spent most of his career
based in the city it's a very
diverse and multicultural city probably
you know up there as the most so in the
country really so for me what i hope is
it's going to inspire local people to
move you know to help them with their
health and well-being physically
mentally and so for me that's what i
kind of look at hopefully is the legacy
of the game
but the backdrop to these games is a
cost of living crisis
there's no doubt the facilities for the
games will be state of the art but with
millions of pounds of public money being
spent there are people in birmingham
asking what's in it for me
in the shadow of the stadium a
community's really struggling
this boxing club has been fighting for
funding but so far received nothing
they have children here whose parents
can no longer afford the two pound
lesson fee but they let them stay for
free if we wasn't there i think after
the kids
would be out on the streets ran the
chips up hanging around with the mates
but off to no good romantic money in the
council spending and to me which on
things that they don't need to do how
about
going around to a few smaller clubs
football clubs swimming clubs boxing
clubs going to see what they're doing
keeping the kids off the street etc and
making donations from the clubs
but organizers insist communities are
benefiting with hundreds of new homes
and the creation of jobs all part of the
plan the city will see well in excess of
a billion pounds invested into
birmingham as a result of hosting the
games i absolutely believe that the
people of birmingham will look back on
the commonwealth games and say that was
the moment this city changed for the
better
but doubts remain over whether that
change will be felt by everyone in the
parts of the city most in need of help
becky johnson sky news birmingham